[Musique]
étranger
lorsque
les propriétaires veulent nous céder leur emploi,
nous leur demandons de remplir un formulaire et
nous leur demandons d'expliquer pourquoi ils
abandonnent leurs chiens et je dirais
que cette raison particulière de
l'immigration était simplement gentille  d'un
petit pourcentage parmi toutes les raisons
pour lesquelles les gens abandonnent leurs chiens, mais
ces jours-ci, c'est presque la seule raison
comme peut-être huit demandes de reddition sur dix que
nous avons reçues viennent avec cette raison,
donc je dirais que oui, la situation est
assez grave
[Musique]
[  Musique]
ma
[Musique]
toi